buy it just at a discount
the thing is the very things
men value in women decline
exponentially after 35. it's especially
childbearing which is one of the biggest
things women don't just lose a little
bit of value as far as like from 35 to
36 to 37 they almost double in every
year in their in their loss of of their
if you like value for men so the every
year from 35 onwards you are doubling
how your your effectively your sexual
market uh downfall
uh and so by time you hit 40
barely any men are
as in again
let me let me caveat this we're talking
about high earners high level men those
one percent 10 percent guys not your
average joe every average simp will
find the same average because the
average is the majority
but what happens i think if we think
about just because
economics right economics is all about
supply and demand in it so it's all
about
who wants and what they want so to say a
woman is expired it depends if you're
looking for a child-bearing man and
you're 35 plus then yes that's a bit
much darling a child bearing china
[Laughter]
a man that wants children and you're 35
plus then that's probably the wrong zone
for you darling that's when you need to
have a reality check and realize where
you actually are
but sometimes you can be a 40 year old
man who's already got children from
previous relationships you're not
looking for kids anymore very true
you're looking for a good woman to
settle down with and just have life live
lavish go on a cruise and do whatever so
you don't care about her whether she can
bear children anymore you might not even
care too much about her looks because at
the same time you might not even be a 10
out of 10. you might not consider this
to be a 10 out of 10. you're not saying
yourself you know what i'm only a five
so
isn't that but at 35 that's what men's
peak is
so typically they want younger women
that that thing is what i was going to
say i think he has a point you know so
what i said earlier about the mindset
and kevin simon has actually said this a
rest in peace to the godfather he said
that a lot of guys especially into their
early 40s where they've dated very
attractive women they'll like they'll go
down and look because they just want a
woman to be nice to them
do you know what i mean and i think a
lot of guys experience that
the most attractive women who get a lot
of attention because maybe they put
themselves out there and stuff because
they're getting a lot of attention and
it feeds their ego etc understandably so
they actually don't um
they're actually not that nice they're
not that kind so i think
there is some value in
if a woman has the right kind of mindset
if even if she's older
for some men that's actually better than
a young attractive girl
right who maybe is a is a headache i've
heard the opposite that younger women
are easier to mold and that older women
are stuck in their ways
i think i think that i think that
element is true but
i i think especially the younger
generations like where the younger the
generation the more entitled they're
likely to be this is what i'm thinking
because nowadays i think the younger
generation they feel like
this is what it is this is what it
should be city girl life this is how it
should be until i decide that it's the
other way around so i think they're a
lot more stubborn than we give them
chris because
a woman in you could like even said a
woman who gets to her mid 30s she has a
reality check
and i think that's actually why most
average guys are
are nice because guys have a very early
reality check in life
yeah
d okay question for the man i'm gonna
ask you guys this first
do you want a woman to settle for you or
you to settle for a woman
i would rather settle for the woman than
i'll settle for i have to be
the
top choice yeah 100 so you you'd rather
you'd rather go down i'd rather go down
yes okay
well i mean i think i think for my
situation
it's never never been really it's the
the it's not a choice per se it you have
some control over the the types but
really
the woman is the one who makes the final
call
as far as dating sexual access to sex
all of that stuff is all in the women's
court relationships
not religious relationship that's the
only part that's the only
at the end of the day someone's more
into the other one person likes the
other more than they like them it's
never equal yeah
so even in the relationship yeah oh yeah
it's true there's there's always
somebody someone's compromising yeah
there's nothing on one side at the start
there's always somebody that likes each
up some the other party more than the
other and i would prefer that back just
going back to the question i prefer that
to be the woman that likes me more that
i would prefer
back to the question i would prefer um
should be to be her job yeah i would
prefer to be her top choice personally
that's just that's just my own personal
thing just because
would
and it's funny it's hard for men to say
that
like the words subtle because like men
don't really use that word it's like a
woman that's how we say even if it's
true and they're kind of funny what
about you um
what was what would i would you rather
be settled for or settle for a woman um
i would rather settle for a woman okay
yeah so you guys would rather go down
and looks and up and how much she likes
you yeah for a relationship yeah yeah
relationship yeah long term it it's
almost a must yeah because if she's if
she's always thinking that she can do
better than you it's just this this this
kind of almost like this march to the
electric chair you can see it coming at
the end
you're just marching a slow march it's
that green line
as you say that then would you not then
feel a frustration in yourself and
saying i can do better than you why are
you irritating me you're always nagging
me about this and that i can do much
better than that if she is though if she
is the type that is nagging you then
yeah you you you may get that impression
that like you know you know you know
what you know i'm better than you know
you know i i said settled for you right
i think it's easier for men to
compromise than for women it is though
i feel like they're more likely than
they understand yeah and because i think
men it's easy for me to compromise i
think
i would say i'm gonna say this i'm
biased but i think the best dynamic is
that he is her top choice and he settles
okay women
what do you guys think would you rather
a guy settle for you or you settle for
him i think i'd rather
i settle no
i don't know
can i just add something yeah
i think the
issue that you have when a woman settles
for a man is that women are naturally
hypergamists so women are looking to
secure
the highest valuable man that they can
secure and so
if she settles
and then finds a guide that she goes
he's better in
she's going to naturally want to go
and then you have the issue where you're
breaking up her home
on the basis of your hypergamy which is
natural and so men don't naturally
yeah they jump they don't monkey branch
yeah i guess i guess that's why i'm like
but you know picky that's yeah i
wouldn't you know what it may be you
know what i think it's hard though
because like as women we don't like the
word settle we don't like to think that
we're the ones being settled for
that was just a harsh word
you're settling for me like if someone's
settling someone is it's either it's
either him or you
what are you picking him are you who's
settling he's settling he's settling
okay
i don't know
that's just a tough one
we asked we asked the tough we asked the
tough questions out here
i feel like because i have before
settled-ish
you didn't like it i'm sure
yeah
no i've settled for
someone that
so when you have when you say settled
what do you mean like was he ugly
yeah i'm very okay
okay very very very then why'd you date
him
because i liked who he was as a person
so but obviously it was all like a
persona and once i actually got to know
the person he was
very
i don't want to use the word toxic
because i know how it's seen but he was
diagnosed with narcissistic personality
disorder so it's not like i'm just using
the term okay so it was very very toxic
so i did settle
so that's why i'm like i don't know if i
want to do that again or if i would
prefer it to be the other way around
yeah yeah so so what do you got to pick
one
i think the other one like put them to
they would settle for you yeah